en este vídeo en vez de colocar dos
cargas voy a empezar colocando nada más
un entonces aquí voy a poner una carga
que va a tener magnitud q y vamos a
pensar que es positiva lo que quiero
saber es qué sucede si coloco otra carga
cerca de esta vamos a pensar que estamos
en el espacio o bien en el vacío
entonces lo que quiero saber es cuál es
el impacto neto que tiene esta carga
sobre la otra qué es lo que sabemos
bueno pues por el vídeo pasado sabemos
que si ponemos otra carga digamos con
una cara y también es positiva entonces
éstas van a empezar a alejarse de modo
que esta carga está ejerciendo una
fuerza sobre ésta hacia afuera y si esta
carga la pusiéramos más cerca esa fuerza
sería mayor entonces esa es una noción
importante verdad si tenemos una carga
dependiendo de donde pongamos otra en
qué lugar del espacio pues esta carga
inicial va a ejercer una distinta fuerza
en esta carga que pusimos vas pues a
ello a esa noción justo se le conoce
como como la noción de campo
y es como la cosa que tiene una carga de
que afecta el espacio que afecta a otras
cargas que están por ahí se puede
debatir acerca de su existencia y de
hecho hay que ser cuidadosos con su
definición formal ahorita vamos a pensar
que si existe y lo vamos a tratar de una
manera muy cuantitativa utilizando la
ley de culona la ley de colom dice lo
siguiente la ley de colom recordando lo
del vídeo pasado dice que la fuerza la
fuerza entre dos cargas es igual a una
constante k la constante de coulomb
multiplicada por las dos cargas que en
este caso serían q mayúscula la original
y con minúscula bueno x q minúscula y
eso dividido entre la distancia de las
entre las dos cargas para la distancia
entre las dos cargas que sería esta de
acá y esta distancia que estoy marcando
ahora ojo a veces esta distancia también
la puedes ver como r de radio y eso se
debe a que justo en este contexto todas
las cargas que pongamos a la misma
distancia
a la misma distancia de boer van a ser
igualmente afectadas vale bueno entonces
estoy acá es es la ley de colon pero lo
que nos interesa para el campo eléctrico
es entender bueno o sea cuál es la
fuerza ejercida por esta carga pero por
cada unidad de carga que ponemos
entonces lo que vamos a hacer así
cambiando de colores arbitrariamente es
dividir ambos lados de la ecuación del
colon entre esta q minus entonces le voy
a poner dando ya no quiero un círculo
voy a poner
efe entre kun
es igual acá porque entre de cuadrada
sale simplemente dividimos entre q de
ambos lados y esto lo que nos da ya es
la fuerza por cada carga que por cada
unidad de carga que colocamos y justo a
esta expresión es a lo que le vamos a
llamar el campo eléctrico que se denota
por que el campo eléctrico generado por
q entonces para cada distancia y bueno
así para cada distancia pues tenemos un
campo eléctrico distinto verdad y
tenemos una carga fija para cada
distancia tenemos un campo eléctrico
distinto bueno vamos a hacer un pequeño
ejemplo vamos a utilizar este mismo
dibujo y pensemos que esta carga q tiene
una magnitud de 1 por 10 a la menos 6
globos
desde la menos 6 kilos y lo que nos
interesa es el campo eléctrico el campo
eléctrico a una distancia a una
distancia de dos metros vale como le
hacemos para calcularlo pues simplemente
aplicamos la definición del campo
eléctrico
campo eléctrico es igual a cada porque
entre b cuadrada que es 9 por 10 a la 9
que te lo puedes aprender o tenerlo a la
mano por q que es pero no por 10 a la
menos 6 1 por 10 a la menos 6 y esto
dividido dividido entre la distancia al
cuadrado que aquí sería entre 2 al
cuadrado 2 al cuadrado vamos a ver
cuánto nos queda si esto es igual a
igual a 9 por unas 910 a las 9 por 10 a
la menos seis es 10 a la 9 menos 6 o sea
10 al cubo o sea nos quedaría igual a
dividido entre 4 y esto es igual a 2.250
y aquí hay que ponerle unidades cuáles
serían las unidades de campo eléctrico
pues nos vamos para acá para verlas y
son serían newtons / culo entonces
serían newtons / culo me sale entonces
el campo eléctrico es de 2 mil 250
newtons entre colom ahora una cosa para
de que es que teniendo el campo
eléctrico podemos saber qué sucede al
colocar una carga bueno y conociendo la
magnitud de esa carga y para eso nada
más tenemos que despejar la fuerza ahora
de este lado de la igualdad déjame
hacerlo con con el color verde de esta
misma fórmula tenemos que la fuerza es
igual al campo eléctrico por la carga y
eso te lo digo porque en algunos
problemas puede que nos den el campo
eléctrico y la carga que ponemos vale y
nos pidan determinar la fuerza por
ejemplo podríamos hacer algo así en este
problema podemos pensar que no sé qué
justamente esta carga de acá esta carga
que es la que está a dos metros a dos
metros y que esta carga es de déjame
pensar en algo fácil vamos a pensar que
es de un culo me vale un culo entonces
si nos pidieran determinar ahora si la
fuerza que ejerce esta carga sobre esta
o bien la fuerza que está actuando entre
estas dos pues digo podríamos usar la
ley de culo porque sabemos todo pero
aprovechando que ya tenemos el campo
eléctrico pues vamos a determinar la
fuerza usando esta fórmula de acá que
nos quedaría nos quedaría que la fuerza
es igual al campo eléctrico que ya
tenemos 2.250 newtons por culo x menos
uno menos un culo a ponerle enlace
entonces esto nos quedaría menos dos mil
250 newtons eso es un montón de newtons
pero tiene que ver con que aquí puse una
una carga muy grande sale ahora pregunta
cuando esta es la magnitud de la fuerza
hacia dónde va la dirección pues la
dirección iría hacia con mayúscula
verdad porque son cargas de distinto
signo entonces vamos hacia allá
era una carga positiva por ejemplo esta
que habíamos puesto antes entonces la
fuerza iría hacia afuera muy bien
entonces estos son algunos problemas
facilitos lo que quiero hacer ahorita es
ver si podemos dibujar el campo
eléctrico para agarrar un poquito más de
intuición visual de lo que sucede al
poner una carga déjame bajar tantito y
voy a poner una vez más una carga otra
vez vamos a pensar que esta de aquí es
positiva
vale entonces hay dos formas de dibujar
esto del campo eléctrico una primera
forma es ir poniendo cargas en la orilla
de esta carga o sea ir poniendo algunas
como partículas de prueba y esas
partículas de prueba por convención
siempre son positivas vale entonces qué
sucedería si pusiera digamos una
partícula positiva por aquí pues
entonces iría directamente hacia abajo
así radialmente déjame ponerla
al aire más radialmente si pongo una por
acá y allá si pongo una pura cada iría
hacia ya entonces el chiste es ir
poniendo flechitas que ir poniendo
flechitas que nos digan hacia dónde iría
una carga positiva ahí tendríamos otra
más por acá tendríamos otra más
voy a poner algunas cuantas vale
entonces esto bueno es una forma de
visualizar el campo eléctrico porque
justo nos dice hacia donde sería una
partícula y también nos habla un poquito
acerca de la magnitud y cómo le haríamos
para platicar acerca de la magnitud con
este dibujo pues podemos hacer la prueba
del área unitaria ya que se refiere esta
prueba pues se refiere a que tomamos
digamos un cuadrito de área pues uno por
aquí vemos cuántas de estas líneas pasan
por ahí aquí nada más sería una verdad
luego tomamos un cuadrito por otro lado
digamos por acá
vemos cuántas líneas pasan estas líneas
se conocen como las líneas del campo
magnético y bueno en el cuadrito en el
cual pasen más líneas como que tenemos
esta noción de que va a haber una mayor
fuerza magnética y un mayor perdón una
fuerza mayor fuerza eléctrica y una
mayor campo campo eléctrico vale es
igual por acá tenemos como que varias
flechitas y así sucesivamente bueno esta
es una forma de dibujarlo va y nos da la
intuición de que si estamos más adentro
entonces la fuerza va a ser mayor hay
otra forma de dibujarlo en el cual lo
que hacemos bueno en la cual lo que
hacemos es pintar es pintar los vectores
de fuerza dependiendo de donde estemos a
qué me refiero con esto por ejemplo si
estoy aquí cerca el vector de fuerza va
hacia allá en esta lista se parece mucho
a esto pero déjame poner algunos otros
para contarte cómo es entonces pues
todos estos o sea si ponemos partículas
ya no pegaditas sino a una pequeña
distancia pues hay una gran fuerza hacia
afuera verdad pero esta gran fuerza es
igual
si la distancia es igual entonces todos
estos puntos sus flechas tendrían que
ser de la misma magnitud ahora la cosa
padre viene cuando nos vamos tantito
hacia afuera por ejemplo aquí ahora el
vector fuerza ya no va a ser tan grande
como éste ya no van ya no va a tener una
magnitud tan grande entonces ahora nada
más llegaría como hasta ahí digamos
entonces otro por acá llegaría nada más
como esta
bueno un poco tendría que ir así como
radialmente si siempre es radialmente
hacia afuera entonces llegaría como
hasta acá este como hasta acá entonces
más o menos esa es la idea bueno éste va
un poco más alejado estaba un poco más
alejado entonces conforme nos vamos
alejando tenemos flechas cada vez más y
más cortas hasta ahorita nada más tengo
flechas de de dos tamaños pero también
podría poner una flecha por acá que ya
tiene magnitud muy pequeña
entonces el chiste es poner justamente
las flechitas en la dirección que van y
con el tamaño que le corresponde según
la distancia entonces éste se ve un poco
más padre verdad porque tienen flechas
de muchos tamaños
flechas de muchos tamaños entonces esta
es una segunda forma de dibujar y en
realidad podemos hacer campos magnéticos
no solo para una carga ósea podríamos
hacer campos magnéticos digamos al tener
una carga una carga positiva y por acá
bueno lo voy a quitar la q va a ser ha
sido una carga positiva
y por acá una carga negativa entonces
también podríamos hacer el dibujo del
campo magnético causado ahora por las
dos entonces cómo le hacemos digamos por
con este método podemos poner un puntito
por aquí y nos fijamos qué trayectoria
seguiría acuérdate que esta carga tiene
que ser positiva por convención entonces
lo que haría es alejarse de ésta porque
son del mismo signo pero eventualmente
ésta empezaría a jalarlo entonces haría
como algo de este estilo si la ponemos
aquí entonces sería directamente para
allá
para allá va para allá
tiene esta dirección si la ponemos por
acá hace ahora esto verdad si la ponemos
más arriba como que el brinco es mayor y
así podemos seguir dibujando varias
líneas qué sucedería si la ponemos aquí
en este extremo pues empieza a alejar
pero ésta nunca empieza a tener efecto
verdad entonces pues nunca empieza a
jalar perdón de esta flecha va para allá
se empieza a alejar y ahora si la
ponemos por acá bueno podemos pensar en
que llega de este lado bueno entonces no
es que ésta llegue de este lado sino una
que ponemos por acá en atrás y entonces
bueno también podríamos dibujar este de
acá y también le podemos aplicarla
la técnica está del área unitaria por
ejemplo por aquí hay poquitas líneas
pero por aquí si nos acercamos si nos
acercamos pues ya hay más vale bueno
espero que estas ideas y te ayuden a
entender un poco más qué es esto de
campo eléctrico va que ya tenemos aquí
representaciones visuales para
entenderlo mejor pero la idea con la
cual quiero que te quedes es que un
campo eléctrico es dar a una cierta
carga fija como esa carga afecta a
cargas que vamos a poner alrededor de
ella vale entonces bueno es todo más o
menos fue para para darte una intuición
al respecto y bueno ya nada más para
hacer un último problema déjame en
déjame leer spirit y este problema que
está aquí en el libro
y el problema dice dice lo siguiente
dice calcula voy a apuntar los datos en
color amarillo y se calcula la fuerza
eléctrica nos piden la fuerza eléctrica
la fuerza eléctrica que se ejerce en un
electrón electrón
electrón que se pone en un campo
eléctrico
de 100 100 newtons por culo otra vez
este va a ser un problema muy facilito
va lo cómo le vamos a hacer pues bueno
nos da en el campo eléctrico nos dan que
es un electrón si sabemos que es un
electrón conocemos la carga entonces la
fórmula que nos conviene utilizar es la
de fuerza es igual a carga por campo
eléctrico es la que teníamos allá arriba
y entonces pues a cuánto sería igual
esto
esto sería igual a la carga del electrón
que bueno no me la sé de memoria pero
afortunadamente aquí el problema dice
que es de menos 1.6 por 10 a la menos 19
entonces nos quedaría igual a menos 1.6
por 10 a la 19 esto de aquí sería cool
oms verdad y eso hay que multiplicarlo
por los 100 100 newtons por colom
entonces cuánto nos quedaría a esta
pieza la menos 19 nos quedarían menos
1.6 por 10 a la este 10 al cuadrado
entonces menos 19 más 12
-17 entonces serían menos 1.6 por 10 a
la menos 17 newtons muy bien entonces
como puedes ver los problemas son muy
sencillos aquí nada más puede hacer una
multiplicación lo difícil y lo que
realmente vale la pena es entender la
teoría detrás de esto es entender pues
todas estas cosas desde que cerca de la
carga cerca de la carga tenemos mayor
fuerza lejos tenemos menor fuerza
entender un poquito cómo se visualizan
los campos magnéticos perdón los campos
eléctricos para entender la la idea
detrás de pues de esta fuerza verdad y
también pues entender un poquito esto de
las líneas de campo y del método del
área para aproximar un poquito la fuerza
eléctrica y el campo eléctrico bueno nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo